freunde herzlich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video heute ist ein besonderer tag
nicht sagt warum ich hab ja letztens ein
video gemacht durch shirin david frost
getestet habe und ein hotspot hatte ich
mir vor allem eingebrannt und zwar der
köpfte lanig direkt zu beginn habe ich
habe um ehrlich zu sein noch nicht so
häufig kräfte gegessen und es war so
krank lecker deshalb habe ich mich dass
ich bin jetzt kräften fällen und es gibt
ja einen deutsch rapper der für kräfte
steht wie niemand anderes gerät
natürlich von katar
und es trifft sich dass partei jetzt
gerade neu in den supermarkt kräftespiel
herausgebracht hat das ist keine werbung
oder so aber der liebe hat macht eine
tour an das ist ein köster schließe die
harald grill blog tour da fahren wir
heute eben da teste ich den wohl besten
köpfe die es in deutschland und ich
teste ob er sich gegen den von shirin
durchsetzen kann also leute lasst uns
loslegen
okay wir sind in düsseldorf angekommen
das ding ist wir nehmen das video an den
tag auch wo ihr seht deshalb sind wir
nach düsseldorf gefahren
die sind zwar später auch noch in köln
aber wir müssen so früh gespielt hier
sein und nach meinen informationen ich
habe vorab mit den leuten geschrieben
soll jetzt hier irgendwo wir sind hier
gerade an der potsdamer straße und
irgendwo auf dieser potsdamer straße ist
anscheinend zum einen der nightliner mit
dem die unterwegs sind der krasse
tourbus und natürlich der faktor deshalb
haben jetzt mal rum und machen uns auf
die suche sehr aufgeregt ich habe vor
allem hunger ich habe mich bis zum stück
extra nicht nur zustimmen zu dem
zeitpunkt dachten wir tatsächlich noch
dass das alles an einem tag klar aber
was dann alles noch passiert ist guckt
euch selbst an
leute wir sind gerade diese potsdamer
straße einmal abgefahren und es ist
einfach nicht hier
ich hoffe mal dass ich nicht irgendwas
verdeckt habe guckt euch das mal an die
geht quasi einmal hier komplett um und
wir sind einmal rumgefahren und es ist
wirklich nicht ansatzweise irgendeine
spur von food truck hier ich muss mal
gucken wie man erreichen kann weil
brauche auf jeden fall meine kräfte
spiel ist es geht uns jetzt wollen wir
platz die info bekommen
katar wo gestern noch late night im
studio und normalerweise wird das ja
auch gar nicht so angekündigt also ist
jetzt nicht so als würde er die leute da
warten lassen wir waren die einzigen die
schon vor ungefähr wussten wo es hingeht
wir müssen jetzt aber ein bisschen zeit
totschlagen und da dachte ich mir machen
wir einfach selbst mal köpfte spiels wir
fahren jetzt zum nächsten kaufland und
probieren die kräfte spitze zu kaufen
aero.de zitiert rechnet okay der plan
steht wir fahren uns jetzt selbst kräfte
holt damit wir auf jeden fall einen
haben egal ob wir ihn noch treffen heute
oder nicht aber ich glaube ich bin
zuversichtlich das wird auf jeden fall
klappt wir sehen uns gleich auf der
suche nach dem kopf und vor allem können
wir dann natürlich auch den direkten
vergleich ziehen zwischen den
tiefgefrorenen köpfe um den freshen aus
dem wagen okay leute wir sind jetzt
direkt vom kaufmann stephan rein ich
habe schon die gelegenheit geklärt wo
wir die jetzt zu bereiten könnten also
wenn sie jetzt da sind kommen wir auf
jeden fall auf unsere kosten besuchen
oh mein gott kräfte spieße h wald wild
und nichts da es war noch vier nein das
ist das letzte wie schmerz wirklich also
der betrag muss auf haben heiß begehrt
die letzte packung verlassen leider kein
köpfte spießt aber ist ja halb so wild
wie werden sie ja frisch vom grill das
essen heute deshalb machen wir jetzt mal
auf die suche aber bereiten erstmal das
zu wie sie es noch mal zu einem weiteren
kaufland gefahren weil wir lassen uns
nicht unterkriegen und es dauert
anscheinend auch noch ein zwei stündchen
bis der track dastehen wird beginnen
jetzt rein und ich sage heute ich hab es
ihm gespürt da wird es jetzt gekaufte
spiel zu geben
wir sind hier gerade durch alle regale
abgelaufen haben gesucht gesucht gesucht
mit mitarbeitern gesprochen die meinten
sie wissen nicht ob es gibt aber hier
sind hier einfach er sich direkt doppelt
freuen die ihr wisst gar nicht was ihr
heute alles schon gemacht haben für
diese kräfte spitze wir sind jetzt extra
ins büro von den leitzins gefahren aber
die haben keinen herd wir haben gerade
einweg grills bestellt damit wir endlich
diese dinge hier zubereiten können ich
habe das letzte mal vor über einem
halben jahr gegessen und ich freue mich
so darauf wirklich leute wird expecting
erstmal preis die vier euro für
verlachte fünf euro für kräfte die ist
auf jeden fall schon eine ansage aber
ich meine es auch einen liebhaber
produkt auf jeden fall wir sehen hier
natürlich steht auch noch mal das
original von parteien oder wird keinen
hehl draus gemacht soll man auf
grillpfanne zubereiten 300 gramm sind
das 240 gramm sind diese mini falafel
bällchen und
ich verspreche euch der nächste schritt
ist der wo wir das endlich zu bereiten
[Musik]
wie lange hat es gedauert bis dieser
teller vor mir ist freuen
ich kann es gar nicht mehr reden damit
gar kein reden russ köpfte verlaufe wir
haben jetzt noch ein bisschen homos und
fladenbrot geholt gemerkt es auch leicht
an regnen aber ich glaube es wird so gut
schmecken
[Musik]
normal sagt ich also krank krank saftig
und geistig sehr krank waffe waren ganz
kurz in der mikrowelle probiere ich
hatte mir schon gedacht das ist nicht
sehr knusprig sein kann wenn es aus der
mikrowelle kommt und im regen steht aber
wirklich sehr sehr gut stoff wenn die
frittiert werden
ich muss jetzt ein bisschen davon was
verdrücken bei mir sehr gut merken wie
das ganze schmeckt weil als nächstes so
gott will essen wir ja qatar kräftespiel
von ihm selbst gemacht so freunde wir
sind jetzt an der location angekommen wo
in köln das ganze stattfinden soll
da steht doch schon mein gott da wir
haben es geschafft hawa das ist der
nightliner darin sitzt glaube ich das
ganze team und den food truck haben wir
zwar noch nicht gesehen aber ich dachte
wir sind auch ein bisschen früh leute
werden wir es doch noch schaffen und den
echten hammer griff des spiels essen
[Musik]
also leute das erste was ich jetzt hier
vom charakter kesse falafel wir haben ja
heute schon mal selbst zubereitet ich
bin gespannt ob die noch besser sind ja
noch
es ist einfach deutlich deutlich crunchy
halten wir es hinbekommen haben also not
sind mit die besten fahrer für nicht
gegessen
[Musik]
ich erkenne jetzt was vor allem beim
kochen innsbruck ganze machen kann
torsten ist ein bisschen soße und 2002
das sind die von conti ausschließen also
das original köpfte sandwich haben
gerade sogar erklärt bekommen wie es
gemacht wird vor simpel wir haben ein
softes brot gerne tomatensoße bisschen
petersilie und dann die kräfte
ich habe extra noch mal gefragt vor die
soße ist so schön so schön schattig und
die kräfte spitze sind die gleichen wie
es im supermarkt zu kaufen gibt es halt
ich bin sehr gespannt wie schmecken wird
wir haben jetzt den ersten biss hat es
sich gelohnt das alles auf uns zu nehmen
ich habe das video ja angefangen mit
dass sich letztens auf syriens fotos
video gar die kräfte gegessen habe damit
probiere ich gerade ein bisschen super
gleichen scharf große kommt sehr gut was
ist klasse ich kann es nicht sagen sind
zwei verschiedene arten von köpfte aber
das ist wirklich super lecker also was
hat die jagd nach dem kräfte spies
ergeben wie ist das finale ergebnis
gewesen der kräfte war es super lecker
sucht wie kann ich nur sagen der
eigentliche kräfte spies also die
frikadelle war ultra lecker also nochmal
geiler als selbst angebracht bei auch
das mit dem einen wickel schon ein
bisschen stil hatte der frikadelle
selbst gebe ich auf jeden fall neun von
zehn aber man muss sagen das war etwas
was aus erlebnis ausgelegt war das war
ein persönliches erlebnis
ich würde dem gesamtprodukt nur sieben
von zehn geben deshalb nicht ganz so
stark wie das was sie bei schwerin david
gegessen habe aber wirklich auch wenn da
einiges schief lief war das wirklich ein
ereignisreicher tag das hat sehr viel
spaß gemacht und zwar vor allem gut zu
sehen ich weiß nicht ob das auch mit
bildmaterial rübergekommen ist diese
ganzen kev aus dem block da einfach nur
sich gefreut haben das ist glaube ich
auch der hintergedanke hinter der aktion
und kann man nur feiern deshalb fette
props am katar danke das ist vorbei
schauen durfte er kann euch dass ihr
zugeschaut haben wir sehen uns am
sonntag wieder macht es gut bis dahin
und schafft